[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK ORLOVE: Hey,
everyone, and welcome
to another episode of CE TV.
We are graciously hosted
by the Cloud and Air team.
They run these amazing technical
webinars every Tuesday.
So make sure you continue
to tune in and watch those.
Today, I'm super excited because
we have two of the hottest
topics in cloud--
big data, and machine learning.
And to help me with
that, I have one
of the amazing Google Cloud
product managers, Abhishek,
with me.
Abhishek, would you mind
introducing yourself?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Yeah, thank you, Nick.
Hi, everyone, I'm
Abhishek Kashyap.
And I'm the product manager
and really delighted
to be here and talk to
you about BigQuery ML.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
Yeah, so big data, machine
learning-- for any of you
out there who are
playing buzzword bingo,
now's your time to bring
out those scratchcards
because I think that we'll
be highlighting some pretty
exciting stuff going through.
So in order to start
talking about BigQuery ML,
I think we should at least
first cover what BigQuery is.
So for any of you who are
unaware of what BigQuery is,
BigQuery is our fully manged
enterprise data warehouse
solution that essentially
provides enterprise features
and functionality for
those real-time SQL
queries that you need to run.
It's pretty unique
because it has
Google's unique backend
architecture of separating
compute and storage so
that, as you scale up
your compute environment,
as you scale up your storage
environment,
basically, everything
is completely seamless to you.
All you see as the end user is,
you upload data to BigQuery,
you hit the giant big red
button that says Run Query,
and you get some results.
And the other amazing
thing is that, because it's
fully managed, Google takes
care of your encryption,
takes care of the reliability,
availability, all that stuff,
all that typical heartache
and heavy weight with managing
clusters, all that
kind of stuff.
So we take that burden
off of our users.
So Abhishek, since
we're going to be
talking about BigQuery ML, why
are those two topics related?
Why big data plus
machine learning?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: There
are two topics related
because, if you think about
where the world industry is
going, there used be a lot of
historical analysis of data.
If you look at the journey of
analytics on data in the data
warehouse, everyone use to
clean their data processor
to build dashboards and
present to executives
and make decisions
based on those.
NICK ORLOVE: Sure.
Yeah, that makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: But
all these decisions
were based on historical trends.
As we see the advent of
machine learning and machine
learning at the scale to
work on terabytes of data,
all these decisions could
be made in a predictive way.
So rather than using
somebody's wisdom
on what's going to
happen tomorrow,
you could actually
have machine learning
apply to every decision
that gets taken.
And the way we see this
manifesting is, just
like BigQuery made it
very, very easy to go
from having to manage your
clusters, and the node size
and the performance to only
thinking about analysis
and writing SQL to
do the analysis,
we believe machine learning
should be the same way.
You should not
have to think about
the underlying infrastructure.
How many nodes do
I need to provision
to build a machine
learning model?
Or do I need to split my
data into cleaning and test?
Yes, you always should.
So what if we
automated all of these
and build the machine
learning foundations
where their data is, which,
in our case, is BigQuery?
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
Yeah, that's exciting stuff.
Yeah, so I'm a
little bit curious.
How have customers previously
used BigQuery plus machine
learning in the past?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So if you
think about a typical process,
since it's really
hard to do machine
learning where the
data is, the first step
is people end up exporting
data to an object store.
And from there, if you
are a data analyst,
you would take a small sample to
Sheets, do a linear regression.
You have an idea to
improve the model.
You go back, export more data,
and do it all over again.
If you happen to be
a data scientist,
you can take your
favorite Python framework
and convert the data into frames
that that framework takes,
build your model.
To improve, you go
back and get more data.
That's the process
that you follow.
And it takes hours and days
for each iteration just because
of the backend
work that's needed.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
I can see an issue
just-- not only for time,
because it takes time
to obviously export
the data from BigQuery,
import into GCS,
or whatever your framework
is, but also, you're
starting kind of a bad trend
of creating data silos.
You have multiple data sources
that you have to manage.
If you're updating your
BigQuery dataset in real time,
now you have to somehow get
those over to the GCS buckets.
So I can definitely see
that as a big challenge.
How are we how we kind of
running into those issues,
and how are we
dealing with those?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And
actually to this point,
it's actually OK to
have silos in GCS.
We have seen data scientists
having silos on their laptops.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
Good point.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: People will
build models on their laptops.
NICK ORLOVE: Fair point.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And then they
share with each other using
email and SEP.
So that's the extent of the
silos that are being created
with the current processes.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
And so these challenges--
how are they typically
affecting companies?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yeah.
So the two challenges
we see are, one--
most companies do not hire
enough data scientists.
And it's not that
they do not want to.
If you just do a simple
search on LinkedIn,
you'll find that there are
maybe up to 1 million data
scientists.
And if you think, how
many of those million
can actually go ahead and
write your best-in-class neural
network, that number is
probably 1/10th of that.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
Makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And
if you start thinking,
well, I need to do
reinforcement learning, that's
probably thousands of people.
So the first problem is, if you
are going to have so few data
scientists, there is no way that
you can apply machine learning
to more than 2%, 3%, 4%
of the business problems
that you deal with.
The second problem is, as
I walk through the process,
it takes a good six to eight
hours in just setting up
the infrastructure, even if
you know what you are doing,
to build your first model.
So iterations actually
take a lot of time
because you have to set
up [INAUDIBLE],, set up
data transfer.
You have to set up conversion
of data from one format
to another.
And that's actually a big,
big productivity inhibitor.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
That makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And that's
what we are trying to fix.
So we launched
BigQuery ML in beta
in July at our conference
in San Francisco.
And it allows anyone who knows
SQL to do machine learning just
using SQL without having
to learn Python or R
and within BigQuery.
So you do not have to
move the data out either.
And that's what BigQuery ML is.
It is simply Machine Learning
using SQL in BigQuery.
And it actually makes ML
accessible for all audiences.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
That's a good point.
So in Google Cloud, we
have different paradigms
of machine learning.
So on one side of the
spectrum, you have the ML APIs;
you have AutoML.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
you have full customization
with the cloud machine
learning engine.
And so it seems like this
is a good middle ground
because machine
learning is incredibly
transformational across
all of our customers.
I mean, I've seen and heard
some really incredible stories.
And so I feel like what we're
doing as Google is empowering
all sorts of users,
whether you're
a developer, a backend
engineer, SRE, SQL developer--
all these kind of
groups and users
now have the power to bring
machine learning to whatever
it is that they touch.
That's pretty awesome.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yeah, exactly.
So if you think about what's
needed to have machine learning
be pervasive across
organizations,
we believe democratization
is what's needed.
You need to build
tools for people
and have them use machine
learning where they are.
You cannot expect that your
developers, to data analysts,
to data scientists-- all of
them will pick up Python and R.
And they all will
be a data scientist.
Rather than doing
that, we believe
we need to provide tools.
So anyone can build a
machine learning model.
And BigQuery ML
specifically targets
the gap where you have these
data analysts who understand
your domain, who
understand the data,
but they do not have the
tools to build a model.
So we have TensorFlow
for data scientists
to build a state
of the art model.
We have AutoML, Cloud ML APIs.
So developers can just call
an API on standard problems
like object detection.
But there's a big gap in terms
of, you have your custom data,
custom business problems.
Data analysts are the only
ones who understand it deeply.
And they can now
start using machine
learning using BigQuery ML.
NICK ORLOVE: That's
awesome, very exciting.
So how does it really
work in the end picture?
How does that look
for the end users?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yeah.
So if you think
about an end user,
the end user can now just
log into the data warehouse
or go to a notebook or
wherever they are writing SQL.
Stay in SQL to build a
machine learning model.
Stay in SQL to train the
model within BigQuery.
So you actually
bring ML to the data
rather than taking data to ML.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
That makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And finally,
I'll show you in a demo,
just with a couple
lines of SQL, which
is machine-learning specific,
you can build a model.
So you do not have to worry
about hyperparameter tuning,
basic feature
transformations, which
are needed for almost
every machine learning
model [? you build. ?]
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
And I'm curious, what
kind of customers
are using BigQuery ML?
And do you have any example
use cases that you can share?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Definitely.
So we usually run a private
alpha before we launch a beta.
And we had a very
successful alpha.
These are some of the
public references who
agreed to share their use case.
I'll start with
Hearst Newspapers.
So media companies are usually
spending a lot of effort
on reducing churn.
And in their case,
they wanted to start
doing predictive churn
modeling to do marketing
campaigns to people who are more
likely to churn, as an example.
NICK ORLOVE: Sure.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: To
do that, they started
working with BigQuery ML.
They managed to write their
first churn prediction
model within a day.
NICK ORLOVE: That's awesome.
That's impressive.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And the
model actually combined data
from six different sources.
And since this
was SQL, they were
able to do the join staying
in their SQL platform.
And post their join, they
just built a model in BQML.
And then they set up a
pipeline using Cloud Composer
to do retraining
and do predictions
and to have a dashboard that
writes the marketing campaigns.
And they managed to
finish the whole process
within a couple of
[? scripts. ?] So that's what
they got by using BigQuery ML.
20th Century Fox-- they
actually introduced a product,
in our [INAUDIBLE] demo.
They have a lot of business
decisions that they make on top
of the recommendation
system they have,
which is actually a pretty
state-of-the-art TensorFlow
recommendation system.
But the business decisions
are things like, OK, which
audiences should we market to?
Which movies should
we greenlight?
And having those actually
takes up a lot of data
scientist's time, which,
like everyone else,
they don't have a lot of.
NICK ORLOVE: Sure.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So they use
machine learning in BigQuery
to build classification models
to decide which audiences are
more likely to watch
an upcoming movie
and market to them accordingly.
Similarly, there
are other companies
who have used it for a
variety of different use cases
where they had a lot
of data in BigQuery,
but they did not want to
go through the process
of exporting it and
setting up multiple tools.
And they did not have
enough data scientists
to have working on every problem
that they need to address.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
So the trend I'm hearing
is not enough resources
in terms of people, analysts,
data scientists to crunch
through massive amounts of data.
And that data is
oftentimes complex.
But not only that, it's spread
across multiple datasets,
multiple tables.
And we're allowing
them to perform
joins to combine this data into
one machine learning model that
gets built. That's
pretty exciting.
That's cool.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yeah.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And that's
what they all are doing.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
And I hear that you
have a demo for us.
So I'm definitely excited
to see this in action.
So what is this
demo going to be?
Walk me through,
and let's get to it.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yeah.
So if you imagine a
typical scenario, which is,
you have data about your
website analytics coming in,
which is Google Analytics 360.
And if you have, say,
revenue data coming in,
a lot of our customers
actually join across the two
to make marketing decisions.
NICK ORLOVE: Sure.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: But the
typical output of this join,
as I mentioned earlier, is
just a chart on a dashboard.
What BigQuery ML
allows you to do
is to actually build a
machine learning model
to do predictions.
And since this is part
of the BigQuery API,
you can actually use
these predictions
to both connect to your action
systems, which in this case,
could be mail marketing
or ads, and to directly
add it to the dashboard
of your choice.
Because BigQuery works with
almost all BI platforms
that are out there.
So you can do both because this
is already in the BigQuery API.
And our customers
already have the set up
of downstream systems.
And it makes it very easy to
add machine learning to it.
NICK ORLOVE: Fantastic.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And to
go to the specific demo
scenario, what we did is we have
public dataset from a Google
merchandise store
that's in BigQuery.
You can actually go browse it.
And if you are a
marketer at any online--
if you sell anything on your
website, what you want to do
is you want to attract visitors
to your website and remarket
to them, to have them
come back and purchase.
But this is a fairly
standard problem.
The issue is that, for the
Google merchandise store data,
we see 0.7% of the
people actually came
back and purchased.
Now, if we are the marketer,
and you know less than 1%
are going to come
back and purchase,
if you blanket market to all of
them, it's highly inefficient,
and it's not going to lead
to as good a conversion.
So what if you
could predict who is
going to come back and
purchase and who is not?
And that's what the demo is.
And I will--
NICK ORLOVE: Other action.
OK.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So this
is the new BigQuery UI
that we recently launched.
And you can see--
I'll make it bigger--
that this is a SQL statement
that's getting data from--
NICK ORLOVE: OK--
the public dataset.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
The public dataset.
And we have data from one year.
So we take nine months
of data for training.
And we'll keep the
last three months
to test to show you
how the model did.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
To verify that it's
actually working, OK.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And
what we want to predict
is if somebody will
come back and purchase.
NICK ORLOVE: Sure.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So all
we need to do for that is,
say, if someone visited,
and there was a transaction,
and this wasn't the first visit,
then it's "will buy later,"
that's true.
And that's what
we try to predict.
We'll select some usual columns,
like where did the person come
from, how many
pages did the person
view, which country, which
medium, which operating system?
And just throw them in as
features and see what happens.
NICK ORLOVE: So the
machine learning model
is going to be built
off of these features
that you specify in
the SELECT statement?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly, yes.
NICK ORLOVE: OK, cool.
That makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Then, the only
machine learning we need to do
is on top of the
SELECT statement
that everyone
knows how to write,
you just say Create Model.
You give it a name.
We are predicting--
which is the labels--
if someone will come
back and purchase.
And this is a
classification model,
so we use logistic
regression for this.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
And question on that--
so for this use case,
we're specifying a
logistical regression.
But what are the other
classification models
that are supported?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: We have
started simple and most useful
with linear regression
and logistic regression
for forecasting
and classification.
But to your point,
we are going to add
a lot more models for different
use cases pretty soon.
And we want to get to a point
where you don't even need
to decide which model to use.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, OK.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: We
can decide for you.
NICK ORLOVE: So
we can use machine
learning to then pick the
accurate machine learning
model?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly.
Yes, exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: I love it.
I feel like "Inception."
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
There was a survey
by Kaggle last year
that actually showed
65% of the models written
by data scientists
are still logistic regression.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
That's pretty large.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So
logistic regression actually
does capture most of the use
cases which are out there.
And that's what we have
seen with customers.
So all I need to do
is execute this query.
This will take
about three minutes
to build on 22 gigs of data.
But what we did was
we went from there
to test on the last
three months of data
because we knew who
came back and purchased.
NICK ORLOVE: Sure.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: We scored
the list based on the model.
There's a function
called ML.PREDICT.
And then we just plotted that
list according to the score,
according to the likelihood of
them coming back and purchased.
And what we found was
that, if, as a marketer,
you only marketed to
the top 6%, 6.5% of them
actually came back
and purchased.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, that's a
lot better than the 0.7%.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, OK.
So that's pretty
transformational.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
So our predictions
are actually fairly accurate.
And more than that,
as a marketer,
you are concerned about recall.
We actually still would capture
50% of the return buyers.
NICK ORLOVE: Wow!
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So we're
just saying Create Model
and giving it a name.
We actually have a
model that's this good.
NICK ORLOVE: That's impressive.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
And if you want
to just look at some of the
evaluation curves, which
we plotted based on the
data from our model,
these actually look really good.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
That's fantastic.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: If you
showed it to a data scientist,
I'm pretty sure they are
going to approve this model.
NICK ORLOVE: With pretty
much two lines of code.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: I mean, you have
the standard SQL statement?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: And then
build a model on top of it.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yes, exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: That's impressive.
Very cool.
And I think we should highlight
on one specific thing.
Oh, sorry-- actually, go back.
I think we should highlight
one specific thing was
that you built this model
with two lines of code.
And this is pretty advanced.
I mean, you have quite
a few capabilities.
So would you mind
touching on that?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Definitely.
So if you think
about it, this model
did not ask you to set up
an infrastructure to train.
We leveraged BigQuery, and we
just created as many processes
as needed to build
this model for you.
And this is going to work on
a petabyte of training date
if that's your use case.
Because you never have to
think about the infrastructure
in BigQuery to make [INAUDIBLE]
petabyte fairly easily.
Secondly, there is a
hyperparameter for this called
learning rate, we auto-tuned it.
You know that you should
not be overfitting.
So if your data is large
enough, we automatically
split it into training and test.
We do a random 80/20 split,
which is the most common.
Numeric features should
never be put in as-is.
So we standardize all of them.
NICK ORLOVE: And I'm
curious about that.
Why shouldn't we be
using numeric features
like dates and stuff like that?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So
with numeric features,
if their scale is really
different across two features,
then one starts
dominating over the other.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, OK.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Let's
say one of features
is weights and pounds
and one of the features
ends up being distance,
and the distance is
up to 2 miles or 2 kilometers.
Suddenly, your weight will
be a dominant feature.
NICK ORLOVE: Gotcha.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So you
don't want that to affect.
Similarly, if one person
builds a model using
weights in kilograms
and one in pounds,
your model will start
looking different.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
That makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So
you want to standardize
your numeric features.
And models work with numbers.
So let's say you have string
features like categories
or Booleans.
So categories you cannot
just feed in X, Y, Z.
We automatically won't hard
encode them to convert them
to numbers.
So these are some
of the basic things
that we do which enable getting
to such a good model so fast.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And if
you're an advanced user--
you know more machine learning--
you can use L1/L2
regularization.
You can select how to split
your training and test data.
So if you wanted a
date-based split,
or if you wanted a
different split in 80/20,
you can specify all those.
And finally, you can set your
own learning rate as well.
The philosophy that
we have is everything
that gets to a better model
is going to be automated.
And things that allow the power
users to get to a better model,
we'll provide them as options.
And that's what we are doing.
So you can always just
write two lines of SQL
and get to a really good model.
NICK ORLOVE: That's fantastic.
And so we've obviously
showed how simple it can be.
But how about some
of the more complex
features, some of the more
complex aspects of the machine
learning?
What do we support
from that perspective?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So we
support creation and prediction
using the model
from Standard SQL.
You can use UDFs with them.
We are starting with two types
of machine learning models.
We'll add more over time.
But to evaluate
how the model did,
we actually have
evaluation functions
which give you ROC curve, or
fixed logistic regression,
specific stats for
linear regression.
We allow you to
inspect the weights
to see how much a feature
impacted the prediction.
And finally, we have
table-valued functions
so you can also analyze
your features to see
how they were distributed.
And that's something
that's very useful
doing feature engineering.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
Yeah, I know that
can be a little bit
complex and involved,
especially from TensorFlow side.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: So it seems like
we simplify this, but still give
you the ability to kind of
do some tuning and all that.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yes, exactly.
And let's see if
the model finished.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
So it did finish
in 3 minutes and 12 seconds.
And if we just go to
the model, what you see
is some basic model
details-- when
they were built, what type it
is, what the last type was.
We use a creative
gradient [? design. ?]
So it shows you what different
parameters were chosen.
And if you look at
the stats, it will
show you the last stats
for training and evaluation
data, and the learning rate,
and how much time it took.
Model schema shows you
the different fields
we used as features
and their types.
So these are the ones we
had in the SELECT statement.
And we are going to
add more charts here,
so you can start looking
at curves, and precision
recall, et cetera.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, awesome,
within the UI itself?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Within the UI itself.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool, that's
going to be useful.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
And for now, you
can actually look
at it in Data Studio
directly off of BigQuery.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, OK.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So we got a
model built on 22 gigs of data.
NICK ORLOVE: Took three minutes.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Three minutes.
NICK ORLOVE: Two lines of code.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
No machine learning.
NICK ORLOVE: That's powerful.
Yeah, no machine learning
experience required.
Cool.
And I think one thing
that we kind of touched on
that we should
emphasize is, BigQuery
is one piece of the entire
Google Cloud data pipeline
strategy.
So before data
gets into BigQuery,
you can perform ETL,
maybe through Dataflow.
You mentioned Cloud Composer.
So you can compose how things
are being run in terms of jobs,
and when jobs start,
when they end, et cetera.
And then finally, the data
that's being stored in BigQuery
is typically in a
tabular format--
so lots of rows,
lots of columns.
And a normal human
being might not
be quite as good at
actually plotting those data
points out if you
have thousands,
hundreds of thousands
of rows, who knows?
And so the amazing thing
is that BigQuery is already
integrated into quite a
few business intelligence
dashboards.
So this data can
already be plugged
into sources like Data Studio,
Tableau, Looker, et cetera.
In fact, one of the
really awesome use cases
that I recently
read is from Tableau
where they took some of
the public data that's
out there on home
prices in Seattle.
And they ran a BigQuery machine
learning model against it
and identified what
would a home cost
if you want two bedrooms,
three bedrooms, if you
want that fancy waterfront
view, or in town, square footage
of the house.
I mean, it's pretty
transformational.
And it's exciting that you
can build something that's
quite comprehensive from just
a couple of lines of code,
spending a couple of minutes.
It's pretty exciting,
so that's really cool.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yeah.
So as a user, if you log
in to their dashboard,
you can manually
type in these fields.
And it will use BigQuery
ML in the background
to get to you the
predicted prices.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: So
it's fairly interactive.
And that's what you need to
use a BI platform for anyways.
NICK ORLOVE: Yes,
exactly, exactly--
how to drill down from the
massive amounts of data
into something a little
bit more meaningful.
Cool.
And I also hear that Looker
has some specific integrations
with BigQuery ML.
So maybe you can
touch on those too?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Yeah, definitely.
So Looker, we have a deep
partnership with where
they have integrated BigQuery
ML to their markup language,
called LookML.
And you can actually create
a model string within Looker
without actually having to
go and write SQL BigQuery.
NICK ORLOVE: OK, without
getting into BigQuery
and running a SQL statement?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly, yes.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And on top
of that, some of the evaluation
charts I showed--
they built some
templates for those--
what they call Looker Blocks.
And they have operationalized
the whole ML workflow.
So Looker customers
can actually start
using BigQuery ML through their
native integration [INAUDIBLE]..
And that where we are headed
with other BI platforms
as well.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool, nice.
Yeah, it's awesome
that everyone is
kind of adopting
this as a feature
and pushing it out to
all their customers too.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Yes, because everyone
realizes that machine
learning is the future.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, I think so.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
And we actually
have talked to a lot
of data analysts.
And they all are taking
courses on Coursera.
And they're all reading up.
And we believe the more
tools we can provide
to make the transition
easier, the better it is,
and the better the proliferation
of machine learning
will be across the enterprises.
And if you just think about your
industry, and think about some
of the business problems,
there are actually
a lot of them which could
be machine learning-based.
And what we have seen is, if
you take retail, and if you say,
I can optimize inventory
in a predictive way,
I can predict
which item is going
to be needed in which
region in what quantity.
That actually, you would think
it's only an efficiency play.
But more than
that, it's actually
a customer satisfaction
play as well.
NICK ORLOVE: OK, how so?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Because
now your customers
in a particular
region are not going
to see longer shipping times.
They're not going
to see stockouts.
So there are lot of operational
supply chain, marketing,
forecasting problems where
just drawing a straight line
from a historical trend is
actually fairly inefficient.
So if you could use machine
learning for each of those--
and some of our users are
actually working with that data
day-in, day-out--
then that's going to have a
great impact on the business
metrics themselves.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
So I think it's important
to also touch on--
since this is a brand new
component of BigQuery--
how to start getting
started with it,
how to get your hands on it.
The exciting thing is that
BigQuery ML is available today
in beta.
And so you can start
using it today,
start building your own models.
Some great resources
for getting trained--
obviously, watching
this webinar helps,
but it doesn't get
you completely there.
So there are some
fantastic blogs
that are out there,
a couple particularly
from a Googler named Lak.
He has written some
fantastic blogs about how
to predict flight times.
I think there's another
one about predicting
natality datasets, which
are really awesome.
So if you Google search
Lak, BigQuery ML,
you'll find probably
like three or four
blogs on that specific subject.
So I'd definitely
give that a read.
Secondly, there
are courses already
out there on BigQuery ML
and actually breaks down
some of the necessary components
around BigQuery, big data,
machine learning, the concepts
behind machine learning.
Because while we've made it
pretty simple for our users,
it's still important
to understand
how the machine learning
actually works in the backend,
the different types of
algorithms, stuff like that.
And there's already a course
on that on coursera.com.
So there are data
insights on course,
which is pretty phenomenal.
I've gone through that myself.
And then obviously, you
start getting your hands
on BigQuery ML, start using it.
And if there's any
feedback that you have,
go ahead and flood this
email address here,
the bqml-feedback@google.com.
I'm sure that
you're going to get
quite a few requests
for feature enhancements
and stuff like that.
And it's exciting that we
can take some of the feedback
from the community and
start building it out
into actual products and stuff.
And that's pretty much
how BigQuery ML started.
So that's really exciting.
Cool.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yeah,
and what we have seen
is, if you know SQL, whether
you use BigQuery or not,
we have public datasets.
You can go to the platform, get
familiar within a few hours.
And you can actually
write your first model
within another two hours.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
If you know it,
it's 15 minutes to
write your first model.
And even if you don't, you
go to our documentation
and follow a tutorial.
And within an hour
or two, you'll
have your first
machine learning model.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And that's
going to be so exciting.
The first time I did it,
when I plotted the results,
I was super excited
to see how close it
was to the predictions.
Then I went back and
tweaked the features,
and it kept on getting
better and better
without me having to go learn
Python, which is a dull task.
[LAUGHING]
NICK ORLOVE: Or understanding
all the linear algebra
requirements that are in the
algorithms for predicting
machine learning.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
That's very cool.
Awesome.
Well, Abhishek, I'm
super-grateful that you
were able to join us with this.
We're going to cut over
to some of the questions
that you guys have
been asking live.
So give us one
minute, and then we'll
be back to address your
questions on camera.
I'm sure there's going to be a
lot of stuff about BigQuery ML.
So glad to have you help
answer those questions for us.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Yeah, delighted to.
NICK ORLOVE: Hey,
everyone, and welcome back.
Thank you so much
for all the questions
that you've been submitting
throughout the course
of this webinar.
We have five really
awesome questions.
And I'm glad that you're here
so that you can answer them
for me.
So I guess jumping
right into it.
"Does my data need to be in
BigQuery to use BigQuery ML?"
I'm thinking, like, federated
queries, that kind of aspect.
Does the data actually have to
be in BigQuery ML or BigQuery?
Or can it be external as well?
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Yeah, so are right.
We can federate from GCS today.
So your data could be
in GCS or BigQuery.
The whole idea of BigQuery ML is
that you bring ML to the data.
And you leverage the
BigQuery's processing power.
So your data, for this to
work, has to be in BigQuery.
Or if it's in GCS,
we can federate.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
And we can just
get it in and use BigQuery ML
NICK ORLOVE: Man, that
makes it pretty powerful.
Because you can query across
multiple sources of data,
therefore, kind of
eliminating that aspect
of having different data silos.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool, cool.
OK, onto the second question.
"How can we use BigQuery
ML on unstructured data?"
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: It depends
on the unstructured data,
what the data is.
If you think about
unstructured as short strings,
say category of a
user, et cetera,
we won't hard-encode them,
and you can use it directly.
If you start thinking
unstructured data as, say,
pages and paragraphs and
phrases, in that case,
that data needs to be converted
to a number for BigQuery ML
to use.
And to convert to that
number, the typical process
is to convert it into
some kind of an embedding.
Like an example could
be, you have a document,
and you use Word2vec to
convert it to a vector
in embedding that
knows which phrases
are similar to which phrases.
And then you can take
those two points,
and you know that closer
points are similar.
And then you can feed those
into BigQuery ML as a feature.
So to work with unstructured
data that's a lot of text,
you'll have to convert
them into some embedding.
And the embedding could be
a traditional NLP technique
like Bag-of-Words, or TF-IDF.
Or it could be
something very advanced,
like Word2vec, Doc2vec.
Or you could also call
AutoML API, or Cloud ML API,
convert it into some
structured semantics
like, which are the entities,
and what's the sentiment,
and use those in
BigQuery ML as-is.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, that's
an excellent point.
Because BigQuery ML is not the
only machine learning platform
within Google.
So if you want to send
some unstructured images,
send them to the Vision API,
videos to the Intelligence API.
And you can get structured
responses, like you said,
sentiment, maybe
identify the nouns,
the verbs, the
content of images.
And you can place those
in your BigQuery dataset,
and then query them
with BigQuery ML.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Exactly.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
That kind of ties everything
together, that's awesome.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yes, and
as you think about some
of the more advanced
applications--
like if I want to do
stock predictions better,
you should also get some
news into the model, right?
NICK ORLOVE: Ah, yes.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Suddenly, you can
start seeing, once you go past
just using structured data,
how easily you can start getting
unstructured data to improve
your model.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
Awesome.
Very cool.
OK.
So jumping to the
third question.
"How do I retrain the
model with new data?"
That's a good one.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
And that's actually
how you would put
it into production.
So what we see is,
depending on your use case,
depending on how quickly
your inherent data changes,
customers retrain it
anywhere from once
a day to once a quarter.
So you have to decide what
the right frequency is.
And since this is entirely in
SQL, through the BigQuery API,
you would use a
scheduling platform.
Like we have Composer,
which is based
on open source [INAUDIBLE].
That could just call
your Create Model query,
point it to the new data, which
could be written as a view,
and just retrain it at the
frequency that you chose.
And then it waits
for the model to be
built since you are calling
it from the Composer API.
And once it's built, you start
using it for productions.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
That seems pretty simple.
Cool, OK.
Number four, "Can I
export a BigQuery ML
model for online predictions?"
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yes.
So exporting as a function is
not provided out of the gate.
But we do provide
ML.WEIGHTS, which you
can use for feature inspection.
So you can take the
weights of the model,
and you can export it to
your online infrastructure
to use the model that way.
So ML.WEIGHTS is the way to
export a model today and use it
for online predictions.
And talking about that--
Lak actually wrote a blog
on this particular problem
as well.
And in that blog, he
walks through step
by step on how you
would set it up.
NICK ORLOVE: OK, cool.
And then final question, "How
does BigQuery ML pricing work?
And I'm thinking in terms of the
slot usage and other aspects.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Yes.
So BigQuery ML-- we have
preview pricing right now,
since it's in beta.
And BigQuery has two types
of pricing structure.
One is flat rate, where you buy
a set number of slots, which
are processing
units, and on-demand,
where you pay for the
data that you query.
So for flat rate, during
the preview pricing,
we are going to include
it with the current slots.
So if you are
already on flat rate,
you use the same
slots for BigQuery ML.
NICK ORLOVE: OK, makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And
then you can mix and match
your other jobs
with ML jobs to get
to a really good utilization.
For on-demand, a
prediction or evaluation
is like a standard query.
So that's $5 at terabyte.
For model creation,
during the preview,
we are charging $5 a gigabyte.
And the reason is, one, even
though it's two lines of SQL,
it's actually a lot
of work underneath
to get to a really good model.
And secondly, it's
taking away a good six
to eight hours of
infrastructure set up.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah,
that also makes sense.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: And that's
the value of this is providing.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
OK, that makes perfect sense.
Cool.
Well, fantastic.
I'm glad you were able to get
through all those questions.
So Abhishek, thank you
so much for joining us.
I'm really thrilled
to have you here.
And for all of our
viewers out there,
thank you for joining the
session on the BigQuery ML.
Up next, we have a session
around Google Slides--
Tips and Tricks.
So you'll definitely want
to stick around for that.
And until next time, I
guess we'll see you later.
Thank you.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
It was a pleasure.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]